the scp foundation does their best to
live up to their famous namesake
they secure and contain anomalies and
monsters from all around the world
or sometimes even offworld and protect
the public from the dangers that these
strange entities might pose
however despite their efforts to
maintain security and keep their
subjects under lock and key
there are sometimes creatures so clever
so devious
and so determined to escape their
captivity and wreak havoc on the world
that even the scp foundation struggles
to keep them from getting free
one example is scp-035
or the possessive mask scp-035 is one of
the most dangerous test subjects in scp
foundation custody
and its mere presence at the foundation
has resulted in untold damage
death and destruction it seems innocent
enough to the untrained eye
the mask which resembles a classic white
porcelain comedy mask
though it occasionally changes its
expression to tragedy
has been in existence since at least the
1800s
in the late 19th century the foundation
discovered the mask in a sealed crypt
beneath an abandoned home in venice
it is unknown how it got there or how
the foundation knew to look for it
if there was ever an explanation for its
discovery that has long since been
removed or redacted from the
foundation's archives
you're probably wondering how can a
simple mask leave multiple season
foundation employees dead
well like everything at the scp
foundation this mask is not
what it seems there is a reason its
classification is ketter
a designation that refers to an entity
that's excessively difficult to contain
and it couples this difficulty with a
pronounced hostility towards human life
and the ability to cause widespread
destruction in the event of a
containment breach
these are the qualities that the poor
unfortunate souls assigned to guard
scp-035 would come to understand
all too the possessive mask is a
parasitic entity
constantly seeking out a host willing to
put it on
any human being in the mask's proximity
experiences a sudden
unexplainable urge to put it on and once
they do
there's no going back scp foundation
research has determined that once a host
has put on the mask
their brain waves are replaced with an
alternative pattern
this one coming from the mask rendering
the host effectively brain dead
once the host brain function has been
eliminated the mask takes over
piloting their body and even speaking
through them however the mask can only
occupy a host for a small amount of time
before the body begins to decay and
decompose
eventually rotting away completely
leaving nothing but desiccated flesh and
bones where there once was a person
scp-035 is capable of possessing any
humanoid being
whether that's an actual human being or
a lifeless humanoid shape
despite all their research the scp
foundation
unknowingly gave the mask all the tools
and resources it needed to break
containment
and leave a trail of bodies in its wake
for a time the mask was given host
privileges meaning that it was purposely
allowed to
occupy a host in order to speak with the
scientists studying it
in order to avoid murky ethical issues
the host was usually something inanimate
like a mannequin or a statue
these conditions however unsettling
allowed the researchers to carry out
interviews with the consciousness housed
inside the mask
in the hope of beginning to understand
it and its motivations
however scp-035 lost all access to its
host privileges
after it almost pulled off an
unprecedented shocking
and nearly catastrophic escape attempt
in its early days at the facility when
it was still allowed host privileges
it was contained in a triple locked room
and monitored by several research
personnel
these were experienced researchers who
had been with the foundation for a
minimum of five years each
an unusually long tenure in such a
dangerous and mentally corrosive line of
work
these research staff members were
thought to be the most capable of
handling interactions with the mask
and be able to resist its attempts at
manipulation
unfortunately these assumptions were
naive
and seriously underestimated the mask's
power
research on the mask indicates that the
mask is incredibly intelligent
and a skilled manipulator it has a
photographic memory
intelligence that would rank it in the
99th percentile of humans
and the ability to incite dramatic
changes in the behavior and people that
it talks to
one particularly in famous interview
between the entity and an unnamed doctor
at the foundation
suggested that the mask may even possess
telepathic abilities
the mask was able to give details about
the doctor's life that no one else was
privy to
including knowledge of an affair that
his wife was having following the
interview
the doctor suffered a psychotic break
and committed suicide just 24 hours
later
the mask is able to use its superior
intelligence charismatic personality
and mind reading abilities to get inside
the heads of those it speaks with
it will pull out any and all
psychological stops to get what it wants
leaving broken minds and spirits in its
wake
it was really only a matter of time
before it used this skill set to its
advantage
and attempted to escape its confinement
the day of the escape attempt was like
any other
the research staff a team of three
intelligent experienced men
checked into the facility measured the
conditions of the mask's containment
unit
and began the process of interviewing
the mask like normal
its motions were slow and looked to
require great effort
as its current host was beginning to
degrade beyond use
the mask was attached to the blank face
of a mannequin and corrosive black
liquid could be seen oozing from its eye
and mouth holes
this liquid is excreted by the mask at a
near constant rate
and it's thought to be at least
partially responsible for the
accelerated decay of the host bodies
in spite of the entity's unsettling
nightmarish appearance
it was just another day's work for the
men assigned to monitor scp-013
and so they carried on with their daily
routine
everything was going according to plan
until one of the men dr jones began to
behave erratically
he demanded that his fellow scientists
leave him alone with the mask for a
while
and allow him to engage in a private
conversation with it
it is unknown what exactly the two spoke
about while the other two scientists
were absent
as the security footage captured had no
sound however
several minutes into the conversation in
the footage dr jones can be seen
dissolving into a fit of tears
laying on the ground and shaking with
sobs as the mask dispassionately watches
he then climbs onto his knees begging
the mask for something
before he embraces it he holds the
mannequin in his arms for
five straight minutes weeping again
before they separate
after this disturbing emotional display
dr jones brought the other scientists
back into the room with him
what happened next is still uncertain
but there are a few things that we know
for sure
the other scientists began to speak with
the mask in later interviews the other
scientists were bordering on incoherent
babbling about various traumas from
their lives
one repeatedly referred to a drunk
driving accident where a dear friend was
killed
and he was at fault another simply cried
out for his mother again
and again whatever the mask said to them
it was enough to completely destroy
their mental health
after the two scientists had been
emotionally devastated by the mask
dr jones escalated the situation further
dr jones removed the mask from the
decaying mannequin body
and shocking everyone who had later
reviewed the security footage
placed it onto his own face once the
mask was in place the security footage
ends
at the command of the mask which was now
speaking through dr jones
the other two men switched off all
security camera monitoring scp-035's
containment facility
the mask piloting the body of dr jones
like a horrible
fleshy puppet made its way through the
facility
avoiding detection until it reached the
exit doors
where it was finally stopped by a team
of over a dozen security guards
knowing the dangers of touching the mask
all foundation employees involved in the
recontainment of scp-035 refused to
remove it from dr jones face
instead he was placed in the locker room
with the mask still on
left alone to be observed over the
security cameras until his body had
decomposed beyond use his body paced
back and forth in the cell for days
flesh rotting and dropping away only
until sinew and bone remained
only when the bones began to turn black
and brittle crumbling apart into dust
did the body finally stop moving his
family was notified
the mask was carefully removed from what
was left of his body
and his remains were destroyed the other
two scientists involved in the scp-035
escape attempt were terminated
and their files destroyed after this
incident a few more failed escape
attempts
and the acknowledgement of the
devastation that could have been caused
if the mask had made its way out into
the general population
scp-035 lost its host privileges
altogether
several research staff protested this
decision insisting that there was more
to be learned from
speaking with the entity inciting
valuable information that it had given
about other scps
however the risk was determined to
considerably outweigh the potential
reward
in the request to reinstate 035's host
privileges were denied
several staff members went so far as to
erupt into violent outbursts on 035's
behalf
attacking their supervisors who refused
to provide the mask with a new host
clawing at them with animalistic rage
any staff members that submitted a
request to reinstate said privileges
were considered a security threat
and reassigned to a different scp or in
some cases
terminated any staff member who had
direct contact with scp-035
was also terminated in order to avoid
the risk of any more staff-aided escape
attempts
the mask is now kept in a hermetically
sealed glass case
and there is a psychologist on call to
provide assistance to anyone guarding it
in case of adverse effects on their
mental health from the mask's presence
personnel that work around the mask even
in its current dormant state
experience frequent violent outbursts
and a higher rate of suicide
even without a host the mask's corrosive
effects have spread across its
containment facility
the walls of the room have begun to
secrete the same black liquid that
emanates from the mask
which tests have revealed to be highly
contaminated human blood
that damages the structural integrity of
the walls following prolonged contact
this blood has begun to form patterns on
the walls spelling out words and phrases
in italian
latin greek and sanskrit as well as
depicting drawings of ritual sacrifice
and mutilation
staff members also report hearing
unintelligible whispering and horrifying
high-pitched laughter when in proximity
to the mask
further exposure to the mask results in
migraines hemorrhaging around the eyes
mouth and nose and an eventual psychotic
brain
between the corrosive substance
appearing on the walls and the physical
and psychological damage to employees
scp-035 is becoming increasingly
difficult to contain
and there are debates among staff as to
whether the entity can
in fact be contained at all as soon as
possible
scp-035 will be moved into a new
containment facility
and its previous cell will be isolated
from the rest of the foundation's
property and destroyed for the safety of
all involved
we can only hope that the new
containment procedures are more
effective than the last ones
and that this mask never makes its way
into the world again
if it does who knows how many lives it
will claim
in the meantime if you ever come across
a strange mask and feel a nearly
uncontrollable urge to put it on
ignore the whispered pleas to just try
it ignore the echoing laughter
and the sensation of something older and
more powerful than you can imagine
rummaging through your deepest darkest
secret thoughts turn around
and run as fast as you can in the other
direction
you'll be glad that you did
you